tout a commencé le 18 avril 1989 lorsque
des milliers d'étudiants rend un hommage
un ancien réformiste et secrétaire du
parti communiste chinois qui vient de
mourir pour ces jeunes c'est l'occasion
de demander une démocratisation du
régime
dans les semaines suivantes les
manifestations s'intensifient et semble
échapper de plus en plus au contrôle des
autorités chinoises qui sont débordés
pendant que certains demandent la
liberté ou la mort d'autres se font
entendre dans la rue
le 15 mai une visite importante va leur
donner de l'espoir celle de mikhaïl
gorbatchev
l'homme fort de l'union soviétique
devenu le symbole de réformes et de plus
de transparence il incarne l'ouverture
dans le contexte d'une situation
géopolitique qui évolue alors que la
hongrie ouvre son rideau de fer et que
la pologne se démocratise
tous les espoirs sont permis pour les
chinois mais devant l'ampleur de la
contestation le gouvernement instaure
alors la loi martiale rien pour
décourager les manifestants qui ne
veulent pas lâcher prise
mais dans la nuit du 3 au 4 juin le
régime en a assez les balles fusent
alors de partout il est jeune tombent
comme des mouches partout on ne compte
plus des blessés on n'a plus le droit d'
équité dans un hôtel à partir de ce
moment là les médias étrangers ne
pourront plus filmer quoi que ce soit
selon le gouvernement chinois il y aura
moins de 300 morts bien plus selon les
organisations internationales qui feront
des bilans beaucoup plus lourds avec
aussi des milliers de blessés et
d'arrestations de ce soulèvement le
monde entier se souviendra de ce jeune
homme sans arme qui tentent d'arrêter la
progression des blindés
celui qu'on a appelé l'homme de
tiananmen où tanks men grimpera même sur
la tourelle du char d'assaut pour parler
aux soldats se rebelle dont l'identité
n'a jamais été confirmé at il été
exécuté
est il toujours en vie à ce jour le
mystère reste entier
ici frédéric arnould radio canada
montréal